keeping cool in whatever way possible
people and animals across continental
Europe are feeling the heat of unusually
high June temperatures just drink try to
don't make too fast or slowly drink
drink drink this hot Sun we try and keep
to the cooler places we've been out
looking at Rome from 8 o'clock this
morning but from midday on we're eating
ice cream it's very good
meteorologists say the soaring
temperatures are due to hot air blowing
in from North Africa but many also call
this heatwave
unprecedented
in France authorities are taking extra
precautions to care for the most
vulnerable the country is still scarred
by the intense heat wave of 2003 in
which almost 15,000 people died isn't
scare mongering these heat waves are
going to keep happening as we know and
perhaps they'll get worse in the years
and decades to come because of climate
change I'm asking everyone to take
responsibility for themselves their
family and their neighbors and to avoid
a backlog in emergency rooms due to
people taking unnecessary risks the haze
was visible over Paris on Tuesday and
pollution levels could rise further as
the mercury climbs in Germany
authorities in the state of Brandenburg
are battling wildfires the area is a
tinderbox after prolonged hot and dry
weather amid warnings across Europe that
midweek temperatures could break records
staying cool remains top of the agenda
well for more on how to cope with the
heat way we're joined by professor Hans
Christian Ganga from the center for
space medicine and extreme environments
at the Charlotte a University Hospital
here in Berlin thanks for being with us
this morning professor thank you
now we're expecting temperatures of 40
degrees and more in some parts of Europe
that could be really uncomfortable but
is it dangerous
actually it's for healthy people it's
really uncomfortable but especially for
people who have certain diseases like
cardiovascular diseases or COPD chronic
obstructive lung diseases they are
really in danger of being hurt by this
heat wave and for normal people as you
say if you're healthy of the 40 degrees
alien temperatures are also for for
healthy people so all people have to be
conscious about this heat wave and they
have to drink enough they have that's my
suggestion that they should wait each
other in the morning and in the
afternoon so that they see how much
fluid they have lost properly so it's
the only way really to calculate whether
you you have really drank enough during
the day because otherwise it's you don't
know really how much you are sweating
under these hot conditions that's a good
tip so weigh yourself in the morning in
the evening evening and then the
difference that's that's not fat all
right so keep your body fluid up how
else can we keep our body temperature
regulated under these extreme conditions
that's exactly the point we can only use
under these heat conditions the
evaporation the evaporation of sweating
from the skin because the usual thing
what we do is we increase our blood
perfusion in the skin but this is not
enough under this condition so the
sweating is the main way to get rid of
the heat because when you are sweating
the sweat is evaporated and during this
process pink coming from liquid to a gas
it takes away heat from the body and
that's why you have to keep especially
your fluid balance
very close I am so hydrate hydrate
hydrate drink lots of water a lot too
much but not too much that's why it's
all because it's very difficult for
people to calculate have I drank enough
they should wait either and then they
see whether it's enough or not okay
now scientists are telling us that the
earth is warming up and that these
extreme heat in events these these heat
waves could become more common do you
think the human organism is capable of
adapting that depends on the reason that
actually for the moment in the
sub-saharan area for example the
temperature are four months too high to
really to work that's why people are
migrating at that entry region and if
the this heat is more expanded to other
regions the people were migrated there
when you look in Germany the coast area
they have 26 okay's if you find yeah but
when you go down to 500 other German
cities or Paris it's extremely that's at
the at the edge just a final question
any other you mentioned people who have
particular diseases or some sort of
health complications already there
particularly at risk anyone else who
should be experienced children children
and children please do not leave them in
the car when you are just going outside
and just for having a short look at the
at the store so it sometimes it's only
need 15 minutes or half an hour that
extremely hot conditions inside so
children and elderly people they are
most vulnerable in front yeah good
advice professor Hans Christian Ganga
from Berlin's Charlotte a hospital thank
you very much for being with us this
morning thank you